hey guys it's Justine we're back with
some more animal crossing and today I'm
going to visit my friends island my
friend Edie you guys have seen him here
my channel before he is I think actually
one of the reasons that I got into
Animal Crossing years and years ago so
today we're gonna check out his island
it's pretty ridiculous but first my able
store just opened up today I'm gonna
need to put on a really nice outfit so I
can look cool for my visit to Ed's
Island this is a really nice outfit and
I actually think ed would probably be
super into it I need to try it on this
is beautiful look at all these outfit
lucky shorts lat
these are beautiful outfits how about
some suck ease oh hello this is the way
to do it I'm going to spend all of my
virtual money oh my god I look so good I
need a hat yep let's do it
oh my gosh my look okay I need to find a
gift to bring ed didn't stop following
me around you're making me nervous
gonna race gonna race or what he would
you know do y'all wanna race the problem
with that is he has probably everything
in this game my house is a mess you know
you can't even let's not even talk about
it anything that he could possibly want
can you bring him a plant I know maybe
I'll bring him miss ironing size I'm
sure he has it already but yes I'll buy
it I think it's a nice offering took a
nice friendly gesture let's go visit my
friend net so nice
his flowers he's put over 120 hours into
this game so like it was Ireland isn't
my outfit looks I look incredible
like I just need everyone to just take a
look just take a look right here my look
oh honey I'll take him serious flooring
maybe let's do a wallpaper as well a
rock climbing wall oh my god am I glad I
bought that but first things first this
is my favorite part he has a little swap
meet so people couldn't like drop things
here okay I'll take a look at it okay
that's awesome part I'll leave it look
at this powers super super cool
oh come one now I'm not even sure a vet
is here he just leaves his island open
and then people just come over to visit
he's not even here this is his office
and he had like a little BRB working
sign he's outside like in the real
outdoors see I should probably drop my
gift for him the ironing set and a
succulent plant my offering this looks
inside of his house I know it's gonna be
ridiculous
oh he's a geek a slider poster oh my
gosh okay I want him to give me the tour
so I'm gonna wait until he gets back hmm
I don't even know who that is
[Music]
do a little shopping let's see what kind
of outfits he's got in his store today
Beauty boys shopping so I don't seem to
be that into his stuff that he has here
I'm happy with my outfit
nope nothing caught my eye today
thankfully maybe I picked one of those
because I need it to make a flower crown
she's nothing good here today we're
gonna buy that maybe what I said I
didn't like any of these and now I'm
losing my freaking mind
no we're done whatever - sure why not
great hey money doesn't spending like a
like a fiend okay great that's how much
money I have spent to add his island
already we're trying to get some fish
and I will wait until he gets back no
sea bass Wow i'ma call one of those
before just kidding
stir fish I'm not catching anything then
I don't have already got all these
flowers ends back he's he's up and
moving hi ed so he's on a FaceTime audio
call right now so this is you know a
real generic way to do it but I think
it's gonna work what is that what just
happened my goodness I've never wrapped
anything what is that what's what's it
gonna be
it's a dolly I picked one of your pink
roses I didn't dig it up I just picked
it and that way I can work
my workspace yeah I definitely have
adopted that because I was leaving mine
open too and I don't think people I
didn't have a signs I don't how to make
one what a great idea I love it oh my
gosh now somebody else is coming look at
that
look Eric is here oh you've got a really
nice brick bridge I just built my first
incline while I'm working on it I'm
gonna tell you I'm gonna tell I'm mad do
you have the aggravation oh I don't have
that ones I'm yelling at Eric do you
think he's upset my favorite thing to do
my favorite thing is just a clap and
like just not stop do you remember that
old YouTube video where a second pan
Denzel Washington watch his head what is
that that's pretty great oh my God look
at your hair that's really incredible
[Music]
oh this is nice look at that last stage
oh my gosh I could perform I'm sorry
Mike
do you know well you know I love am evil
yeah I can't get this fish it's like
I've never fished before
oh my gosh come here's a pig I don't
know I think it's my new shoes that
looks like something I don't have oh my
gosh
freakin missed it I'm not used to
playing on a monitor see you Eric have a
nice flight I am from Promax
look at that I just unlocked the the
updated milk ATM so I can get like this
looks really good the cake a slider
poster up there's incredible
I love the Animal Crossing Nintendo
switch that was definitely worth getting
the switch for I love those floor lights
over there what is this is your game
room yes
do you have an espresso machine not yes
I have all this is from the campus link
to your devices Katherine I did like
mine actually
yeah this is cool this is so moody oh my
gosh I could just hang out here that's
ridiculous can I get in the bath tubs up
shots I know I sold it all oh there's
three of them though do you know should
I get a good camera angle oh oh oh my
goodness
and that takes care of that that's
incredible
all three of them have exited yeah that
looks cool so look there's like two on
the wall I only have in the windows yeah
no way
okay this one is awesome the skulls I
also have a skull flooring it is
glow-in-the-dark turn your lights off
that's a really great wallpaper
I need to do some some work on my house
I like that it goes out into the hallway
to look at your little basket backpack
and here we go yep definitely worth the
wait are you sneezing well thanks for
hanging out wait a minute
is it really five pm oh my god word of
the day go I have to stop playing this
game I'm disgusted with me so I wake up
like two hours earlier now so that I can
get everything done before my shop opens
at 8:00 so I get up at like 6:00 even
though before the quarantine I'd get up
at 5:00 but now it doesn't really matter
nothing matters except animal crossing
well guys that's it for this video
edie has frozen over there well thanks
for hanging out you guys need your
hollow head on instagram at da dead and
on twitter dotted okay bye
[Music]